Harry's Ghost Rider for his Memoir
released an essay about what it was like
to work with Harry interesting timing
what is going on with that is really
interesting timing I mean is it just the
case that he falls out with everyone I
know he's fallen out with his family and
this suggests that a pretty fractious
relationship at times with his ghost
writer and there was apparently a bit of
a to do a bit of uh shall we say
artistic disagreement over one
particular anecdote in the book but
Moringa says it wasn't the first upset
we get the impression that there were
several were there any moments that
stuck out in the essay by The Ghost
Writer well this anecdote about them
falling out and and pointedly The
Ghostwriter says this wasn't the first
sort of creative difference but this
particular anecdote was about when Harry
was undergoing some hostile training and
he was really being pushed his absolute
mental limit I mean two of the other
people in training just couldn't handle
it and one of the people that was acting
out the role of kidnapping Prince Harry
made some some comment about Harry's
mother Princess Diana now we don't
actually find out what that was
and Harry had a comeback and he wanted
this comeback to be part of the passage
in this book he wanted it to show that
even when he'd been pushed to his
absolute limit he could come back with a
witty comment you know to put these
people in their place and the Ghost
Writer insisted that this wasn't
relevant because actually this wasn't
about Harry in that moment Harry didn't
like it there was a real conflict there
and eventually hurried back down and we
understand that this wasn't the only
creative difference they had but there
were several and I suppose when someone
else is writing your story it's such a
personal experience I suppose that is
inevitable
[Music]